전화한 대로 나는 이미 데이터가 있어 이렇게 이야기해도 되겠죠?
이런 식으로 제출을 하셔도 되겠습니다.
이렇게 보통 3, 4개 정도의 질문이 나오게 되고
이 인터뷰를 통해서 요구사항이 구체화가 되면
그 다음 스텝에서 진행되는 거는 한번 보여드리겠습니다.
이건 제가 실제로 이 어플리케이션을 만들기 위해서 했던
그 Agent와의 대화인데요.
이렇게 디자인 MB까지 생성하고
그다음에 인터뷰를 한 다음에는
이 Agent가 인플멘테이션 플랜 그러니까
어떤 계획으로 개발을 진행하겠다라고 하는 계획서를 만들게 됩니다.
그럼 이 계획서를 확인하고
내가 마음에 들면은 그대로 승인을 해서 진행해도 되지만
저는 이렇게 Firestore에 관련된 내용을 수정을 요청을 했고요.
수정을 요청하면 다시 인플멘테이션 플랜을 업데이트하게 됩니다.
이런 과정으로 전체적인 개발에 대한 계획을 하고 난 다음에
그 다음에는 이제 전문 서브 Agent을
여러 개 동시 가동해서 계획한 대로 구축해줘라고 명령을 하게 되면은
동시에 여러 가지 서브 Agent들이
이제 주로 뭐 프론트 핸드 Agent
그 다음에 뭐 백 핸드 Agent
그 다음에 결제 Agent 이런 식으로 여러 Agent가
동시에 구동되면서 개발이 시작되게 됩니다.
이렇게 병렬로 동시에 가동 중인 Agent 현황을
이제 계속해서 보실 수가 있고요.
구축이 완료될 때마다 완료된 내용에 대해서도 받아볼 수 있게 됩니다.
이렇게 구축이 완료되게 되면은
이제 빌드를 실제로 하게 되고
이제 터미널에서 명령을 입력해서
개발 서버를 구동할 수 있게 됩니다.
이것조차도 이 Agent 책이 요청을 하실 수도 있습니다.
이렇게 개발이 완료되면은
이제 제가 아까 보여드린 이렇게 지금
로커루스트에 이제 개발이 완료된 그런 페이지를 보실 수가 있게 되고요.
여기서 이제 검증을 하는 거죠.
내가 원하는 결제 시스템이 정상적으로 작동하는지
한번 확인해보겠습니다.
확인을 해보게 되면은
이렇게 제가 프로덕트를 구입하겠다.
지금 재고가 32개 남아있는 프로덕트를 구입하겠다 라고 하겠습니다.
그럼 이때는 이제 내가 연결된 지갑이
정보가 나오게 되고
이거에 대해서 구입을 하겠다 라고 했을 때
지금 저는 빵원이기 때문에
이제 샌드박스 모드로 결제를 전환하여 진행하는 건
제가 여러분들에게 보여드리기 위한 용도로 이렇게 만들어봤습니다.
그러면 이것도 여러분들에게 보여드리기 위한 용도로
이제 페이의 샌드박스 모드로
실제로 결제를 전송하는 과정을 한번 확인을 해보실 수가 있고요.
이렇게 페이먼트가 완료된 다음에는
이제 영수증이 나오게 되고
이 영수증을 확인하면
결제 완료까지 되는 흐름을 확인을 하실 수가 있습니다.
그리고 또 이제 그러면 이제 앞으로 왔을 때
지금 보시다시피 재고가 32개였는데
31개로 줄어든 게 보실 수가 있고
이게 db와 정상적으로 연동이 잘 됐는지 확인을 하시려면
이 차저에 들어가서
이 차저에서도 이 스톡이 31개로 바뀌었는지까지 확인하시면
db와의 연결도 잘 된 거를 이제 검증하실 수가 있게 됩니다.
이렇게 검증까지 완료돼서
로컬에서도 잘 되는구나까지 확인을 하시면
클라우드런에 배포하는 것까지 요청을 하실 수도 있습니다.
이 클라우드런에 배포해줘라고 요청을 하게 되면
이 에이전트가 클라우드런에 배포할 때는
도커 기반으로 배포를 하기 때문에
도커 파일을 생성해 주게 되고요.
도커 파일이 생성되면
도커 파일이 기반으로 배포를 할 수 있게 됩니다.
배포를 하게 되면
저희 클라우드런이라고 하는
저희 서비스 콘솔에 들어가시면
배포가 정상적으로 완료됐는지 확인을 하실 수가 있는데요.
저는 이 테크미 쇼룸이라고 하는 이름으로
정상적으로 배포가 완료된 상태입니다.
이 배포가 완료된 상태에서
그러면 이제 들어가 보게 되면
지금 보이시는 것처럼 똑같은 이제 웹페이지지만
여기 지금 이 클라우드런에 URL로
그 접속을 했을 때
요 페이지가 나오는 걸 확인할 수가 있습니다.
그리고 이렇게 웹페이지가 나왔을 때도
또 한 번 검증을 해보셔야겠죠.
이번에는 검증할 때 AI 어스탄트 기능을 넣어놨기 때문에
이 어스탄트 기능이 잘 작동하는지도
한 번 검증을 해보도록 하겠습니다.
지금 제품 중에 키보드 제품을
한 번 두 개 구입해 보도록 하겠습니다.
이 AI 버튼을 선택을 하게 되면
요것도 재미나이 3종 플래시 모델을
사용하도록 연동을 해 놓은 상태이고
이렇게 이 제품을 이렇게 갖고
요청해 보도록 하겠습니다.
그러면 이 두 개를 구입했을 때
총 가격에 대해서 나오게 되는데요.
지금은 제 지갑이 연결되어 있지 않기 때문에
이렇게 너무 잘 나오는 걸 보실 수가 있고
이 셀렉트 월렛을 해서
한 번 커넥트를 하고
그다음에 한 번 다시 승인을 해서
진행을 해보도록 하겠습니다.
이번에도 제 잔액이 영원이기 때문에
이제 샌드박스 모드로
한 번 진행을 해보도록 하겠고요.
이렇게 페이먼트가 정상적으로 완료된 것까지
확인을 하시고
이 경우에도 성공적으로 마무리된 것까지
보실 수가 있습니다.
이거는 지금은 AI 요스턴트가
사람의 개입에 따라서
결제가 이루어지는 것이기 때문에
실제 결제 프로세스는
사실 버튼을 클릭하는 거랑
크게 차이가 없다고 보셔도 되겠는데요.
완전히 AI가 이제
결제를 대행하는 그런 흐름으로 생각해 보면
예를 들면 제고가 영인 제품에 대해서
제고가 들어왔을 때
에이점트가 자동으로 결제를 하게 한다던지 하는 식으로
사람의 개입 없이
에이점트가 결제하는 흐름을 개발하시는 것도
가능할 것 같습니다.
이렇게 좀 부족한 시간이 약간 부족해서
제가 좀 서줄러서 말씀을 드리긴 했는데
이런 식으로 최종 결과물이 나오는 게
일단 디자인 자산이 나오게 되고요.
이 디자인 자산을 가지고
최종적으로 웹사이트를 만들게 되고
이 웹사이트에서 이제 저희 지갑과 연동을 할 수 있게 되고
그리고 결제를 할 수 있는 이 흐름에 대해서
쭉 해보실 수가 있습니다.
저는 사실 정말 기본적인 웹페이지를
만드는 걸 보여드렸는데
여러분들의 아이디어를 가지고
이제 커톤에 또 반짝인 아이디어로
한번 참가를 해주셔도 좋을 것 같습니다.
지금까지 제가 보여드린 구글 클라우드의 제품을
실제로 좀 이렇게 학습해 보고 싶으신 경우에는
지금 저희 구글 클라우드 제공하는
코드랩스라고 하는 저희 튜토리얼이 있습니다.
이 튜토리얼 들어가시면
안티그래비티 2.0 제품 분야로
한번 이 튜토리얼을 검색해서
한번 테스트를 해보시면 좋을 것 같고요.
특히 그 중에서도 스티치와 안티그래비티를 연결해서
활용하는 실습이 있습니다.
이 실습을 보시면 제가 이제 잠깐 보여드린
그 스티치 MCP랑 연동하는 과정을
한번 테스트해 보실 수도 있고요.
또 이 코드랩뿐만 아니라 저희가 이제
그 이 런닝 시리즈를 보여드릴 수 있는
이 런닝 플랫폼도 있기 때문에
이 안티그래비티로 간단한 게임 앱을 만들어 보는
이 랩도 해보실 수가 있게 됩니다.
그래서 이제 구글 클라우드의 제품들을 이용해서
이제 바이브 코딩을 하시는데
많은 도움이 되셨기를 바라고요.
이상으로 마치도록 하겠습니다.
감사합니다.
오늘 너무 아이디어가 이렇게 따비스까지 되는 과정을
너무 일본별련하게 잘 정리해 주셔서
감사드립니다.
네 그러면 이제 저희 마지막 세션이죠.
이 해코톤의 주간사이자
이제 솔라나 파운데이션의 김채린 에스텍 테크님께서
이제 왜 결제 정산의 솔라나인가
그리고 고성등 저비형 퍼블릭
블록체인 솔라나와 테이다 쉐를 비롯한 솔로션이
에이저티 커머스 구현에 왜 적합한지를 짚어주실 예정입니다.
그러면 이제 김채린 김 모시겠습니다.
네 소개 감사합니다.
혹시 화면 잘 보이실까요?
네 잘 보입니다.
네 감사합니다.
네 방금 소개 받은 솔라나 파운데이션에서
에이펙테크를 받고 있는 김채린 입니다.
저는 오늘 이제 왜 이 솔라나라는 블록체인이
에이저티 커머스에 굉장히 맞는 블록체인이고
실행 레이어로서 솔라나가 어떻게 사용 되는지를
조금 소개해드리려고 하는데요.
먼저 소개해드리기 전에 솔라나 파운데이션 에
조금 소개해드려야 될 것 같아서
솔라나 파운데이션에 대해서 좀 간략하게
말씀을 드리겠습니다.
먼저 이제 솔라나라는 블록체인이 있구요.
해당 블록체인을 이제 좀 더 상장시키기 위해서
그 블록체인을 기반으로 해서 더 많은 프로젝트를
유치하기 위해서 나온 조직이 바로
비영리 재단인 솔라나 파운데이션이라고 생각하시면 되구요.
리눅스를 위해서 리눅스 파운데이션이 있듯이
솔라나를 위해서 솔라나 파운데이션이 있다고
생각을 하시면 됩니다.
그래서 저는 지금 한국 베이스에 있으면서
아시아에 있는 다양한 프로젝트들의 기술적인
부분들의 서포트를 많이 해주고 있구요.
이제 개발자들의 위해서 툴을 만든다던가
sdk를 개발한다던가
아니면 이렇게 해코투를 진행한다던가
하는 되게 다양한 것들을 많이 하고 있습니다.
그리고 특히 한국에서는 최근에 이제
스테블코인이라든지 아니면
이제 이런 에이전트에 대해서 조금 더 많은
관심을 많이 가지시는 것 같은데요.
보통 기관 분들이 많이 가지시고 있습니다.
실제적으로 신한 카드 혹은 케이지
이니시스 케이지 파이네이션을 검색해보시면
실제로 이제 저희 회사와 에모유를 개져서
실제적으로 스테블코인과
그리고 이 스테블코인을 통화하룡해서
할 수 있는 것들 예를 들면 에이전트 같은 것들을
실제적으로 기관 입장에서 어떻게 쓰일 수 있는가
그리고 쓰이게 된다면 어떤 유스케이스가 있는가
이런 것들 주제를 굉장히 다양한
poc 같은 것들을 기본되고
한국에서는 진행 중이 있고요.
그리고 이제 이 한국 뿐만 아니더라도
미국이나 다양한 유럽이라든지 다양한 국가에서
솔라나에 사용에 대한 유스케이스를 많이 만들고 있습니다.
그래서 이번 해코투를 조금 기획하게 된 이유도
이런 AI 에이전트에서
이런 블록체인이라는 이런 레이어가 굉장히 많이 쓰이는데
그런 레이어를 조금 더 많이 활용들을 높이기 위해서
그리고 어떤 유스케이스가 나올 수 있을까에 대해서
고민을 하다가 이런 해코톤을 좀 더 기회를 하게 된 것 같습니다.
그래서 제가 오늘 조금 설명드릴 거는
약간 이제 구글 클라우드라든지
에이전트에 대해서는 조금 많이 아실 것 같은데
그래서 여기서 블록체인이 어떤 게 쓰이는 건지
조금 궁금해 하실 분들
그래서 스테블코인이 먼지에 대해서
조금 궁금해 하실 분들이 많을 것 같아서
그런 부분들을 좀 소개해드리려고 하고요.
그리고 그러면 그 블록체인 중에서
솔라나가 먼지 이런 것도 궁금해 하실 것 같아서
솔라나가 페이다 첼 같은 것들 소개해드리려고 하고
마지막으로는 이제 저희가 해코톤을 주치하면서
종국절 어떤 걸 보고 싶어 하는지
그리고 솔라나가 실제 개발하실 분들의 대상으로
좀 팁 같은 거 하나 정도 준비를 했는데
그런 부분들 조금 소개를 드리려고 합니다.
그래서 조금 미리 이미 아시는 개념일 수도 있지만
블록체인의 먼지에부터 조금 설명을 드리려고 합니다.
조금 어려운 말이지만
중계자 없이 신뢰를 코절을 만드는
탈중한 분산원장이라고
보통 저희가 사전적인 의미를 이렇게 말을 합니다.
그런데 이거를 조금 풀어서 설명을 드리면
이제 데이터를 담는 블록이라는 게
체인 형태로 연결되고 저장되는 건데요.
예전에 저희가 금융 시스템이라든지
은행 뱅킹 시스템을 활용할 때는
이게 어느 정도 이제 중앙화된 환경에서 진행이 됩니다.
이 중앙화라는 거는 정보나
이 정보를 옮기는 데 있어서
정보로 새로 쓰는 데 있어서
어떠한 한 중앙 관계자에서
승인에 내야만 그 다음에 있는 거래라든지
데이터를 보관한다든지
그런 것들이 가능한데요.
그런데 블록체인은 이렇게
사나이만 저장이 된 게 아니라
여러 대의 분산화 저장이 되어 있으면서
여러 개의 데이터베이스가 이렇게 분산화 되어 있으면서
사나이의 데이터베이스가 망가지거나 없어지더라도
다른 데이터베이스에 있어서
이 공통된 장부를 유지할 수가 있습니다.
그래서 기존에 있던 거는
거래 정보를 중앙화에 저장되어 있는다면
블록체인은 피얼투 피어로
즉 사람과 사람 컴퓨터와 컴퓨터로
분산 저장하면서 특정
이제 참여자가 데이터를 분시하더라도
나머지 데이터로 그 데이터를 보코화를 할 수가 있습니다.
그래서 이 블록체인은 3가지 핵심을 잃었습니다.
거래 기옥을 묶은 블록을
시간순으로 사실처럼 연결한 구조입니다.
그리고 중계점은 실내로
은행이나 카드사 같은 중간 기관 없이도
다수의 컴퓨터, 노드가 함께 검증해서
거래가 송립하는 구조고요.
위 변조가 사실상 불가합니다.
계속해서 이 다수의 컴퓨터와 노드가
계속해서 검증하면 데이터를 올리기 때문에
잘못된 거래가 올라가게 쉽지 않습니다.
예를 들자면 보통은 비트코인이든 이더리움이든
다양한 블록체인들이 이 책으로 인다고 하죠.
책으로 하는 과정
그리고 어떤 컴퓨터를 돌리는 과정을 통해서
블록체인에 데이터를 올리기로 했는데
그런데 이 데이터를 올리는 과정에서
보통 비트코인이든 이더리움이든
특정 보상을 받게 되잖아요.
그런데 그 보상을 받아서 블록체인 네트워크를 구성하는 사람들이
그 블록체인의 해가 되는 행동을 하지 않을 것이라는
기본적인 경제는 논리하에서 그런 부분에서
이런 시지적인 블록체인을 구성하는 사람들
요소들, 컴퓨터들이 잘못된 데이터를 블록체인을 올려서
그 블록체인을 사용하는 사용자들이
이제 이런 거래 오류에 대해서 당황하지 않게
그리고 실제적으로 그 블록체인을 구성한
비트코인이든 이더리움이든
이런 코인들의 가치가 떨어지지 않게 한 역할을 합니다.
그래서 사실상은 경제적인 논리에 의해서
위변조가 사실상 불가하고
중개자 없는 시위네가 가능하게 됩니다.
그래서 제가 앞으로 되게 많이 쓸 요거는
온체인이라는 요거인데요.
이 온체인이라는 요거는 데이터나 거래가
블록체인 장부에 직접 기록하고
지속되고 실행된다는 뜻으로
실제적으로 제가 블록체인에 올린다를
그냥 온체인이다, 온체인에서 진행이 된다
이렇게 말씀을 드릴 것 같고요.
그리고 실제적으로 이 세 가지 핵심을 기반으로 해서
AI 에이전트와 굉장히 좋은 결합이 유지한다고
생각하시면 됩니다.
그렇다면 제가 조금 더 이런 것들이
어떻게 풀려져 있는지를
조금 더 설명을 드리도록 하겠습니다.
그래서 저는 블록체인을 하나의 서버로 보시면 좋거든요.
예를 들자면 저희가 기존에는
예를 들자면 구글 클라우드를 통해서
클라우드 서버를 올려서
거기다 데이터베이스를 올려서
그 데이터베이스 정보를 저장하듯이
블록체인도 마찬가지로
블록체인이라는 데이터베이스에
데이터를 똑같이 올리는 건데
그 데이터베이스가 중앙화된 서버가 아니라
분산화된 여러 가지의 서버가 구성이 된
블록체인이라고 생각하시면 됩니다.
그래서 사실은 블록체인은
뭔가 저희가 생각했을 때
코인, 비트코인 이런 것만 생각할 뿐만 아니라
그냥 백엔드 서버로서의
다양한 종류의 서버 중에
하나라고 생각을 하시면 됩니다.
그렇다면 이 블록체인은 기존과
조금 기존 SQL에 관한
조금 다른 요소가 있습니다.
바로 스마트콘트랙스 라는 건데요.
조건이 충족되면 사람 없이
자동으로 실행되는 블록체인 위에
하나의 프로그램이라고 생각하시면 됩니다.
예를 들자면 기존에 저희가
예를 들자면 어떤 뭐
자판기를 생각을 했을 때
1500원이 들어오면
콜라를 내보낸다 라는 규칙이 기존에는
제가 1500원을 저만께 드리고
저만 분이 여기서 그러면 결제 되셨고
영수증 드릴게요 하면
제가 그때 콜라를 같이 가져갈 수가 있잖아요.
근데 그게 아니라
저희는 자판기를 조금 떠올리면 쉬운데
그냥 1500원이 넣고
제가 버튼을 누르면 바로 콜라를 내보내는 것처럼
그냥 누군가 중계를 할 필요가 없이
바로 거래가 성사되는 거라고 보시면 됩니다.
그래서 그냥 A 조건이 충족되면
B를 실행한다를 코드로 짜서
블록체인을 올린 거고요.
기존에는 은행이나 카드사 같은
중앙화된 거래기관이 그런 것들을 관장에서
승인이나 거부를 했다면
블록체인 위에서는 그냥
이게 이 규칙이
이 SQL 자체에 내장이 되어 있고
그 규칙을 이렇게 규칙에 맞게 되면
자동으로 그 규칙에 대한 결과가 실행됩니다.
이게 조금 기존에 있던
중앙화된 서비스랑
좀 가르다고 생각하시면 될 것 같아요.
그렇다면 여기서 AI 아이전트가
조금 전목시킬 수 있는 부분은
AI 아이전트는 사실상은
병무 구간이 굉장히 많습니다.
예를 들자면
내가 어떤 거를 결제하려고 했을 때
카드 번호를 AI 아이전트에게
위임하지 않는 한
사실상은 제가 계속해서
이 결제가 맞는지 아닌지
이 카드를 써도 되는지 아닌지
이렇게 해서 허가를 해줘야 되는데요.
그런데 이 스마트 컨트롯이라는 게 있으면
특정 조건을 충족하면 바로
이렇게 바로 작동이 되고
그게 중앙화된 기관으로 관리되는 게 아니라
그냥 정말 이 들어간 로직에서
그 로직이 차비됐을 때 실행되는 거기 때문에
조금 더 사람 없이 자동으로
조그만 맞추면 즉시 실행될 수 있는
그런 기능을 가집니다.
그리고 중계비용이 낮고요.
속도가 그 대신 올라갑니다.
사실은 한 번 배표되면
바쁘게 굉장히 어렵습니다.
버그조차 규칙대로 실행되는 게 있는데요.
그런데 그런 부분이 있지만
사실상은 누구나 이 스마트 컨트롯을 접근을 한다면
그 스마트 컨트롯을 누구나 실행할 수 있고
AI 아이전트든 사람이든
누구나 이 규칙에 대해서
똑같이 작동시킬 수 있다는
그런 장점이 있습니다.
그리고 그 다음으로는 스테이블코인입니다.
사실 스테이블코인에 조금 설명드리기 전에
코인과 토클에 대해서 좀 설명을 드리자면
코인은 블록체인 자체의 기본 합혈을 얘기를 합니다.
예를 들자면 비트코인은 비트코인 때
토클은 비트코인 있고요.
이더리움 블록체인은 이더라는 코인 있고요.
솔로는 블록체인은 쏠이라는 코인 있습니다.
이거는 이 블록체인은 사용하기 위한
수술이라고 보시면 됩니다.
저희가 예를 들면 재미나이를 사용을 했을 때
재미나이를 API를 호출을 하면
저희가 API를 호출하는 데서 비용이 되잖아요.
그것과 동일하게 블록체인은 사용할 때는
그 블록체인은 사용하게 되는 수술을 지불해야 됩니다.
그게 바로 코인이라고 생각하시면 됩니다.
그렇다면 토큰이라는 개념도 있습니다.
이 토큰이라는 개념은 네이티브 SS는 아닙니다.
네이티브 SS라는 기본 화폐는 아니지만
누군가가 특정 블록체인에 찍은 또 다른 자산을 얘기합니다.
누구나 발행 가능하고요.
발행 주체는 뭐 스타트업일 수 있고 기관일 수 있고
프로젝트일 수 있고 개인일 수도 있습니다.
그래서 이 토큰을 발행을 해서
누구나 블록체인 위에 내 자산을 발행을 할 수가 있습니다.
그래서 사실은 기존에 있던 돈을 찍는다는 건
한곤 연행이든 아니면 뭔가 화폐를 관리하는 곳이든
중앙원에는 기관반이 가능한 것이었고
금융 상품을 만든다는 것도
인가받은 허가 받은 기관들만 가능했던 것이
블록체인에 오면서 코인이든 토큰이라는
이런 과정을 통해서 누구나 중앙화된 기관일 개입 없이
자기 자산을 발행을 할 수가 있습니다.
그렇다면 여기서 스테이블 코인이라는 개념이 나옵니다.
아마도 기존에 뭐 NFT하지 다양한 자산에 대해서
블록체인에 올라가는 자산에 대해서 들어보셨을 텐데요.
여기에서 그런 부분에 있어서
그런 자산들 단점은 특정 입의 실물 자산
뭐 달러든 원화든 그런 자산과
1대1로 매칭이 되는 자산이 없었다는 겁니다.
그럼 예를 들자면 저희가 거래소나 이런
암압의 거래소에서 비트코인이나 솔라나를 구매를 할 때
저희가 어쨌든 원하를 입금을 하고
그 원화로 그 특정 코인을 이렇게 구매를 하고
이런 것들 굉장히 일반적인 과정이었는데
그런데 그런 부분에서 비트코인은 솔라나든
가치가 정해져 있는 게 아니라
특정 가치가 원화 가치나 달러 가치나
이 비트코인 솔라나의 가치에 따라서
계속해서 가치가 변화하게 됩니다.
예를 들자면 제가 1솔라나가 있었다고 과정을 해볼게요.
1솔이 있었을 때 그거를 어떤 제품을 사는데
대금을 줬을 때
언제는 솔라나가 100달러였는데
언제는 솔라나가 20달러일 수 있잖아요.
그러면 이 솔라나를 화폐로서 받는 사람도
계속해서 가치가 변동되니까 그런 부분에서 굉장히
이게 리스크가 있다라고 생각할 수 있잖아요.
그런 부분에서 스테이블코인이라는 게 등장을 해서
이렇게 스테이블한 가치, 즉 달러 가치에 고정된
혹은 원화든 유로화든 특정 법정화폐 가치에 고정된 코인이 나오게 됩니다.
그래서 AI 에이전트가 실질적으로 거래를 할 때는
뭐 가치에 그 때그때마다 바뀌는 토큰이나 코인도 가능하겠지만
스테이블코인 같은 안정적인 가치에 갚는 게 중요하겠죠.
그래서 이런 자산들이 블록체인은 백앤으로써 사용하는 레이어에서
발행되고 이동하고 유통된다고 보시면 될 것 같습니다.
그러면 스테이블코인은 되게 다양한 종류가 있습니다.
보통 저희가 딸 스테이블코인을 많이 사용을 합니다.
그래서 보통 스테이블코인은 1달러가 한 토큰을 가치가 고정된 디지털 달러라고 생각하시면 되고요.
USDC가 있고 USDT가 있습니다.
사실 이 스테이블코인은 굉장히 많이 사용되고 있습니다.
비자, 마스터 카드, 이런 카드 네트워크 사들도 굉장히 스테이블코인을
기존에 있던 스위프트 망이라든지 카드 결제 망을 대신 사용할 수 있는
새로운 결제 수단으로 보고 있고요.
그리고 실제적으로 이런 결제 사분만이 아니더라도 은행들에서
해외송금을 할 때 기존의 스위프트 망을 통했던 거를
스테이블코인을 바꾸면서 조금 기존에 있던 레거시 금융망을 개최하려고 많이 하고 있습니다.
그래서 기존의 스위프트는 사실 정산 방식이 이렇게 예를 들자면
특정 은행들이 있으면 그 은행마다 특정 시간을 정해서
그 특정 시간마다 돈을 보내고 정산을 해서 최종적으로 정산해 주는 구조였는데
이런 스테이블코인은 블록체인만 통한다면
누구나 중개자 없이 바로 돈을 보낼 수 있기 때문에
그런 부분에서 채택이 된다고 보시면 될 것 같습니다.
그리고 추가적으로 기존에 금융 상품을 구매한다 어떤 걸 결제한다는 건 사실은
저희가 생각하는 미국, 한국, 중국, 일본과 같은 이런 식으로 이미 금융 인프라가
보편화된 국가에만 해당되는 말이었는데요.
그런데 그런 것들을 스테이블코인을 통해서 라면
누구나 바로 이 스테이블코인을 보내고 받을 수 있기 때문에
지간만 있다면 투어 설명드리겠지만
그런 부분에서도 굉장히 이제 국경 무관하게
사람과 에이전트 모두 사용될 수 있다는 자산, 기계형 현금이 된다는 데 의미가 있습니다.
그러면 지갑이란 무엇일까요? 앞서서 계속 지갑에 대해서 조금 설명을 드렸는데
지갑은 하나의 계좌라고 생각하시면 됩니다.
블록체인에서 내 돈을 담는 하나의 계좌라고 생각하시면 되는데요.
그런데 기존에 은행에서는 저의 계좌를 받으려면
신분증을 해야 신분증이 있어야 되고요.
저에 대한 신용이라는 것도 있어야 되고요.
그리고 인감이라든지 이런 되게 다양한 복잡한 절차가 필요합니다.
그런데 이 지갑은 누구나 컴퓨터, 인터네만 연결되어 있다면
핸드폰만 있다면 누구나 개설이 가능합니다.
이건 이제 암호학적 이런 로직에 의해서
만들어진 하나의 나만의 주소이기 때문에
나만의 계좌이기 때문에 사실상은 누구나
여러 개 무산대로 이 지갑을 만들 수가 있습니다.
그런데 다음 은행은 비밀번호 있어도
제가 신분증으로 제 발급하거나 기획원으로 바꿀 수가 있지만
지갑 같은 경우에는 암호학적인 이런 로직으로 만들어진 하나의 계좌이기 때문에
사실상은 기존 처음에 만들었을 때의 개인 키가 없으면 복구가 불가능합니다.
그래서 AA 아이전트는 사실은 내가 진짜 정말
뭔가 이렇게 드러내고 싶지 않은 은행이라든지
카드 비밀번호 같은 건 전혀 이렇게 뭔가 공개하지 않고
이런 이제 지갑이라는 요소를 부침으로써
그리고 지갑은 없애다가 다시 만들 수도 있고
무한히 만들 수 있기 때문에 부담 없는 하나의 계좌를
만든다고 보시면 될 것 같습니다.
그래서 사실상은 기관에게 뭔가 기관 계좌 없이
직접 자산 보유 결제를 지갑을 통해서
간접적으로 할 수가 있습니다.
그러면 제가 정리드리자면
아이전트 결제를 가능하게 하는 블록체인 3유소는 이렇게 있습니다.
스나트 컨셉트, 스테블코인, 시각.
그래서 이 셋이 모이면 사실 사람 없이도 소프트웨어
아이전트가 이렇게 크게 리스크 없이도
스스로 결제가 정산이 가능합니다.
그래서 왜 블록체인과 AA 아이전트에 대한
필요한 인가에 대해서 답변을 드리자면
AI 아이전트를 계좌를 만들 수가 없고
계설에 대한 신원서를 선상하 필요하다면
지갑은 코드 한 줄로 암호학적 로직에 대해서 생성이 되고
신원 없이도 주소만의 송수신이 가능하고요.
그리고 기존의 금융 시스템을
국가 통화 장벽 여업시간 편의조심 이라면
이제 블록체인에서는 온체인의 지갑에서는
24시간, 7일 국병통화 구간하고
수천의 정산이 가능합니다.
그리고 기존에는 제가 한국에서 미국으로 돈을 보낼 때
한 3에서 3, 4일 정도로 이렇게 시간과
그리고 수수료도 한 10달러 정도가 드는데
껀랑 평균적으로
근데 이 온체인의 지갑은
껀닭 수수료는 블록체인 수수료만 내면 되고
따라서 마이크로페인 워트도 정립합니다.
그래서 이런 AI 아이전트에게 필요한 거는
사람용 금융이 아닌 기기용 결제레인으로
블록체인과의 결합은 선택이 아니라
필요한이라고 볼 수가 있을 것 같습니다.
그러면 이 솔라나 블록체인에서
조금 소개를 드리려고 합니다.
우리가 맥이 있고
윈도우가 있고 리눅스가 있듯이
블록체인에도 굉장히 다양한 종류의 블록체인 있습니다.
그래서 그 중에 솔라나는
결제 정산을 최적하든
고성능 접이용 퍼블랙 블록체인이라고 생각하시면 됩니다.
보통 다른 블록체인은
초당 몇 백 원에서 몇 천 원 정도의 수수료가 지이기도 하는데
솔라나 같은 경우에는
0.00X달러 정도의
거의 0.001 센트 정도의 수수료는 내더라도
이렇게 바로 이런 블록체인 내에서
어떤 에센스를 보낼 거나
결제 같은 것들이 가능합니다.
그리고 스위프트 송금가도 비교했을 때
굉장히 효율적으로 빠르게 송금이 가능하구요.
그리고 이제 이렇게 빠르게
400ms 안에 확정되면서
다른 블록체인 보다는 조금 더 빠르게
결제가 확정이 되고 있습니다.
그럼 이 솔라나는 사실은
굉장히 다양한 기본이 쓰고 있는데요.
예를 들자면 비자, 저희가 아는 카드 네트워크사죠.
저희가 해외 나가게 되면
비자가 이렇게 적혀져 있는 카드를 쓰게 됐는데
쓰고 있는데
그럼 비자에서 실질적으로
USDC라는 스테이블코인을 가지고
은행 대상으로 솔라나에서
정산 시스템을 구현을 하고 있습니다.
그리고 이제 미국의 은행 중 하나인
웨스턴 유니언에서는
USDP라는 스테이블코인을
직접 솔라나에 출시하고 있습니다.
그리고 페이팔은 이미 솔라나 위에
PYUSD라는 스테이블코인을 발행을 했고요.
실제 페이팔이 가지고 있는
해외 송금 플랫폼인 줌이라든지
그리고 기존 유튜브 크리에이터에게
정산되는 거를
은행 계좌, 계좌이체가 아니라 PYUSD로
실질적으로 이 스테이블코인으로
실제 지급하는 데 사용을 하고 있습니다.
그렇다면 이런 대단한 블록체인인
솔라나와 함께 구글 클라우드가 만든
AI 에이전트용 APA 결제 게이트웨이
페이다 셸을 설명해 드리려고 합니다.
그래서 이 페이다 셸은
에이전트나 클라이언트 같은 곳들이
가입이나 계정이나 API기 없이도
유료 API를 한 줄로 호출하고 쓴 만큼
USDC를 정산하는 거를
목적으로 만든 하나의 결제 게이트웨이라고
생각하시면 됩니다.
그래서 사실은 구글 재미나에서는 쓸 수 있는 게 아니라
클로드든 코덱스든
이런 AI 에이전트를 모두 지원하고
이런 AI 실제 CLI를 지원하는
모든 것들이 이 구글 클라우드와
솔라나 파운데이션에 함께 만든
페이다 셸을 누구나
베이트웨이를 끌어와서 사용을 할 수가 있습니다.
그래서 꼭 재미나이만 아니더라도
다양한 AI 플랫폼에서도
페이다 셸을 사용할 수가 있습니다.
그래서 가입 없이 어떤 호출이 가능하고요.
키나 구독이 불필요하고
그냥 내가 충전한 USDC만큼
실시간으로 정산하고
실시간을 결제가 되는 구조라고
생각하시면 됩니다.
그래서 조금 어떻게 동작하는 설명을 드리면
이제 에이전트가 페이다 셸 몽록에서
필요한 EUROAPI, 결제, 검색, 데이터,
이미지 생성 등 하나 고르면
이제 평소처럼 요청을 보냅니다.
코드를 바뀔 필요 없이 페이다 셜로
나 이거 EUROAPI를 통해 처리를 하고 싶어
라고 미리 알려준다면
지갑이 그 금액만큼 USDC를 알아서
지구를 해서 받아오고요.
그리고 사람이 카드넣고 승향을 과정에
거의 아예 없이
그냥 내 지갑이 연결된 잔액이 빠지면서
결제가 되게 됩니다.
그래서 예를 들자면
에이전트에게 USDC 같은 지갑을 지워주고
물 사와줄래? 라고 같은 일을 시키면
필요한 EUROAPI가 나오면
그 이제 페이다 셸이 그 지갑에서
알아서 결제하는 것
이렇게 비유를 할 수가 있을 것 같습니다.
그렇다면 개발자분들 입장에서
조금 이제 조금 더 쉽게 설명을 드리자면
내 에이전트가 있고
페이다 셸이라는 클라이언트 한 질만 붙이면
그냥 내 에이전트에다가 USDC
그리고 특정 USDC만 아니라
다양한 스테블리코인은 지원하고 있는데
해당 스테블리코인을 이렇게 담고
그 스테블리코인을 기반으로 결제할 수 있는
지갑이 생긴다고 보시면 됩니다.
그래서 에이전트가 카드넣고에서
APR을 찾아서 스스로 호출을 결제하고요.
그리고 새 서비스도 코드 수정 없이
페이다 셸을 붙이는
바로 이 AI 에이전트가
결제를 할 수 있게끔 할 수가 있습니다.
그래서 저희가 이 페이다 셸을 기반으로 해서
해당 해커톤에서 보고 싶은 거는
실제로 동작하는 온체의 결제
사람 시갠 없이도 진행하는 자열 결제
그리고 직관적인 UX 명확한 이유
실질적으로 왜 우리가 AI 에이전트로 풀어야 되는가
사실은 한국은 카카오든 네이버든 토스든
굉장히 결제가 편리한 국가 중에 하나거든요.
사실은 저희가 실질적으로 돈을 보낸다고 했을 때
하루 이틀 동안 돈이 붙여서
고생해볼 경험은 한국에서는 별로 없으실 거예요.
그래서 사실은 이런 기존에 있던 플랫폼에다가
단순히 이 블록체인 결제
USDC 결제를 붙인다는 것뿐만 아니라
사실상은 이게 실질적으로 왜 기존 금융에서
혁신하지 못했던 거를
AI 에이전트로 해서 혁신해야 하는지
그 당일성이 굉장히 중요합니다.
그래서 이런 부분에서 직관적 UX와
명확한 이유가 필요하고요.
그래서 그 과정에서
솔라나 결제 스텍을 활용해주시는
저희 솔라나 이번 AI 해커톤 주제에 맞는
굉장히 의미 있는 결과물이 될 수 있을 것이라고
기대를 합니다.
그럼 마지막으로 제가 강조 드리고 싶은 것은
개발 꿀팁 같은 건데요.
이 블록체인이라는 네트워크는 사실은
굉장히 어쨌든 편리하긴 하고
뭔가 중계자가 없어서
누구나 다 사용할 수 있다는 장점이 있지만
반대로 이 블록체인이 멈춰버린다면
기존에 있던 자산을 거래를 할 수도 없고
두번째로는 문제가 생긴다면 당연히
이런 결제를 하는데도 시간이 굉장히 오래 걸리고
그리고 하나의 오류가 나더라도
사실 해킹 위험이 굉장히 많기 때문에
굉장히 조금 많이 무거운 인프라라고 볼 수가 있거든요.
기존 중앙안의 데이터 서번보다는
근데 이제 이런 것들
이런 이슈들이 조금 줄이기 위해서
실질적으로 솔라나는 굉장히
다양한 네트워크 계층을 둬서
이런 실질적으로 가치를 가진 자산에 돌아가는
메인넷에서의 이런 기술적인 오류를
최소화하기 위해서 노력을 합니다.
예를 들자면 저희는 크게
로콜넷 테스트 대부분의 메인넷이 있는데요.
로콜넷은 내 PC에 뛰어 있는 1인용 체인이고
테스트넷은 이 실질적으로 새로운
이런 솔라나 클라이언트
실질적으로 저희가 맥, 오메스 업데이터듯이
솔라나도 계속해서 업데이트를 해줘야 되는데
그 업데이트가 제지로 됐는지
첫 번째는 테스트넷은 활용을 하고요.
이 테스트넷에서 안정적이다 검증을 하면
개발자들의 실질을 테스트하는 대부분의
솔라나 클라이언트 업데이트 하게 되고요.
그 다음으로는 메인넷에 올려서
실질적으로 가치를 가진 자산이
잘 돌아가게끔 합니다.
그래서 이 로콜넷 테스트넷 대부분은
메인넷 순으로 개발을 진행을 하는데
보통 테스트넷은 클라이언트 개발자들을
대상으로 하는 네트워크이기 때문에
사실은 실질적으로 로콜넷 대부분의
메인넷 순으로 이렇게 뭔가
테스트를 하시게 될 텐데요.
99%의 개발까지에는 로콜넷을 추천을 하고요.
마지막에 실질적으로 내가 테스트를 해보고
남들도 접속하는 환경을 만들고 싶을 때만
대부분을 사용합니다.
왜냐하면 로콜넷은 제 컴퓨터만 돌아가
네트워크고 실질 로콜로스트 같은 개념이고
대부분에서는 버셀 같은 개념이라고
보시면 될 것 같은데
그리고 사실 버셀을 한 다음에
실질적으로 내 DNS를 통해서
그 BPS를 실질적으로 만들어서
이렇게 호스팅을 하게 되잖아요.
그런 것과 동일하게 로콜넷 대부분의
메인넷 순으로 개발을 추천을 드리고
웬만한 작업을 로콜넷과 테스트 샌드박스 환경
페이다실은 로콜넷을 띄울 표혜도 없이
샌드박스 환경에서 테스트를 가능하거든요.
그래서 그 환경을 기반으로 해서 테스트를 하시고
실질 대부분에서는 메인넷은
시험 배포 때만 쓰시고
메인넷은 실질 돈이 들어가기 때문에
사실은 그렇게 추천을 드리지 않습니다.
그래서 저희가 기본적으로
이 것도는 평가할 때 보는 네트워크는
대부분의 거로